here are the nominees for Best Original
Score avatar by James Horner fantastic
mr. Fox by Alexander the splott The Hurt
Locker by Marco Beltrami and buck
Sanders Sherlock Holmes by Hans Zimmer
and up by Michael Giacchino
and the winner is Michael Giacchino for
up
the first Academy Award and second
nomination for Michael Giacchino
okay thank you guys um when I was I was
dying and I asked my my dad can I have
your movie camera that old wind-up
8-millimeter camera that was in your
drawer
and he goes sure take it and I took it
and I started making movies with it and
I started being as creative as I could
and never once in my life that my
parents ever say what you're doing is a
waste of time never and I grew up I had
teachers I had colleagues I people that
I work with often my life and who's
always told me what you're doing is is
not a waste of time so that was normal
to me that it was okay to do that I know
there are kids out there that don't have
that support system so if you're out
there and you're listening listen to me
if you want to be creative get out there
and do it it's not a waste of time do it
okay thank you thank you